guys this is gonna be a super special
video because it is a compilation video
of the past 10 years of my experiences
on making videos with the iphone we're
celebrating the 10th anniversary of the
original iphone and for me the iphone
has been I don't even know it's been
life-changing a combination of the
iphone and YouTube and all of the crazy
endeavors that I've got myself into on
the internet it's been a really long
road a lot of people think that these
things happen overnight they don't have
been making YouTube videos for almost 11
years and that's pretty crazy
I've little bit together this video to
look back on some fun and fond memories
that I've had with my phone and waiting
in lines and shattering phones and we've
been through a lot these iphones and I
love you guys have been there since the
beginning so hello to all of the old
hello to all of the new viewers I
appreciate all of you and thank you for
coming along on such a crazy internet
journey so 10 years of iphone guys you
excited?
guys like I said 10 years of me and my
iphone but we're going to start from the
newest videos
we're going to the old videos good idea
Ed yeah good idea where we were where
we are barely are now and then you guys
will see where we came from so this
video will progressively get way worse
and more cringey as we go i think it's
on it's pretty yeah watching back how do
you remember where i remember a lot now
go
there's a hole in my phone a screw here
he's here in all of his glory just don't
even want to touch it because I'm gonna
smudge it up so much already here it is
real gold which is pink one of the
newest features is the force touch so
you'll be able to peek in as they said
hey guys the day of the iphone success
launch and puppy is not coming with us
we're gonna leave you here
you don't want to come is anybody here
yet open up I'm ready
hello Harry go look at you
you look so shiny gold compared to the
silver and we'll have a rules goal
comparison as soon as i get home with my
sister anyway hold on the phone call my
from 6 plus plus plus
hello hi yeah it's really good to hear
from you
welcome to i-10 is abseil I probably
should sell my old one
I was wondering don't need to make an
appointment to come in
that's got to make an appointment for
doing this ball coming and welcome sorry
i'm not from here
I just look at apple okay thank you
because they like we're here we're first
that galaxy s5 it's bigger bigger you
want to boo crowd mentality
department traditionally
why I've been sleeping on the street
money in just three days we do i do but
i think i'm getting signal that's not
fun
we got a phone Cody got some psycho T
naught
pig
alright well this really wish it is your
living
it's an old dog
we're heading up an iphone 6 pre-order
party way back they say the apple store
I don't know oh wait a minute minute
minute far it has not to refresh because
I think we're in line to the model
silver just was at the apple store look
a bit like two o'clock in the morning to
be one of the first dish sort of alive
because i was all yesterday there's
about 40 people in line at ten o'clock
p.m. yesterday in line for their iphone
just got online last night
okay see your face but I know is he
wants to be me then i phone 5s in slate
gray the survey that I did it was
absolutely overwhelming the amount of
goals for the gold phone which hopefully
i'll be able to get soon but this is
this light gray it is in fact quite
slate as you can tell it's like it
almost looks kind of like the silver
this is not go it's not that goal
it doesn't even look almost the same
color as the silver and it should be
already activated and ready to go
because I did activated in store
Justine only waiting for the process
here as she is very disappointing was
not able to get they have no idea that
you really want to turn my gosh it will
it really works pretty well dive into
these folders here's my Apple folder and
this is my camera for safari facebook
rooting for Square weighs fancy
myfitnesspal which I probably should use
a little more often path pinterest
instagram youtube wordpress from a blog
turf pages pose little it's not you with
full message and its home Christmas
present for bravery remember Blazers
right now driven very groundbreaking
went to the farmers pc see things going
you guys might first notice about the
ipad mini is it is much much much much
much smaller let's start so i was
starting up to do a size comparison to
the iPhone to purchase the ipad 2 with
there's no penalty as you can tell is
significantly smaller i'm actually quite
surprised found my old iphone and when I
turn it on
this is what happens nothing please work
I really want to use you know I want to
get all of the pictures and whatever
else is on here i want to get off of
here may have to take it to the Genius
board today is set over 21st 2012 to
hello dear
yeah the day of the iphone 5 and i just
got mine in the mail so excited
don't move taken out of check it out
shall we
neighbor right and we're gonna help but
there it is beautiful shining shimmering
splendid
hey Siri are you better than you were
before I'm sorry I'm afraid I can't
answer that his box
goodluck goodluck may notice that
there's nothing in it is box was
delivered with nothing in it was
supposed to be in it
iphone for us i can transfer driving but
make sure your call costly please help
your reason for calling today because I
opened up my UPS box that was supposed
to have my new iphone 4s and there was
nothing in it it's gone
ok I think I don't want to help however
well you know send me
in the car the iphone for free and it is
627 and I can promise you that I will
never be the first person in line for
any sort of applicant
no way is brianne look excited she is to
be here
CSU shirts for itself
look how excited she is I'm in line for
after five
you guys didn't get it
timeline for the one coming out next
year
building ok
sorry launch day and I work life of a
lot of using you want you to get one yet
I figured I was gonna wait anyway the
end to things that take 48 hours for
activation or my computer like can buy
today and I did this without hacking or
jailbreaking my iphone is extremely easy
to use so all you have to do is download
this 99-cent app is called frosty place
now once you have downloaded and
installed click on it click Japanese and
you'll get that emoji option that you
want to click to on
hi friends
so the apple store ok i just want to let
you know finally officially friends have
an iphone also this current point I'm i
also have three iphones this one's going
back to eating your call is important to
us to place order line and an apple
representative will provide assistance
now we don't know we pulled out tonight
all out earlier we just recently ran out
now we thought okay we around three
o'clock we are sold out
it's fine yeah but like I think doctor
ordered
it's a long time is fine just gonna be
great
and exploitation to ok that's wonderful
got my first AT&T bill
in a box
standing right in front of the
the iphone i'm drooling a little bit
it's going to be spinning around shortly
and be able to see the front of it
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video it was kind of crazy
to look back and see how much things
have changed myself internet the entire
landscape of digital media has all
changed so much and I'm so excited for
the future so i will see you guys there
and I'm gonna stop only by their as
everyone how I travel
we're gonna have so many of the same
blog there's gonna be like 70 can we get
will start using on the lawn anyway
tackle didn't at least a dried-out old
we're trying